[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
go
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
and hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a ship she dreams of wind in ourselves
wind in ourselves
unfold
and shining as
we cross the sea
we cross the sea
for hope
then we'll all raise
of voices
and our eyes
on distant shores
with wind in ourselves again
they'll be cheering coldly
[Music]
no more squabbling
[Music]
when we have the wind in
ourselves
[Music]
when we have a fade
[Music]
they'll be feasting and pleasure
[Music]
no more rationing and measures when we
have the wind in ourselves
[Music]
when we have the wind in us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
to
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
a ship she dreams of
wind in her cells
of wind in herself
and shining as
we cross the sea
we cross the sea
[Music]
our voices
a song in
our hearts
and set our eyes on
distant shores
with wind in ourselves again
they'll be cheering coldly
[Music]
[Music]
when we have the wind
[Music]
we also
[Music]
no more rationing and measure
when we have the wind in
all sets
[Music]
when we have the wind in us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
an eel wind blows from beyond the
horizon
a new danger is coming on the tides
and the one who might stop this ruin
trapped for all forever in the sea of
the damned
now to save the pirate life
you must start by saving the life of
one
oh didn't realize we had company
captain jack sparrow but i suspect you
already knew
that
because of the treasure jack storm a
darkness
followed in here and if it's not stopped
this world will sink into shadow
this sea holds many secrets
ah a new body unlocks all i can do is
show you the way
from what i hear of this so-called sea
of thieves
it's nothing but curse crews
bloodthirsty mermaids
a legion of dead angry pirates
oh yes and now one davey jones
well i believe that now is the perfect
time to use these cannons
a world without the eternal face
is a world that refuses to face the
truth
nothing lasts forever destroy that
i don't suppose by chance there's a
second one of those
the sea of thieves i bring me that
horizon
hey everyone welcome to the sea of
thieves of pirates life showcase
we are so excited and proud to give you
a glimpse into how we brought jack
sparrow into our world an early look at
some of those
first couple of tales as well as some
behind the scenes interviews with
members of the development team just to
show you how amazing it's been to work
on this and how excited
everyone is to have had this opportunity
and sea of thieves has never been in a
better place we've had over 20 million
people play
we've been adding content for over three
years so whether you've been on that
journey with us or you're new to the
adventure and this is the first time
you're experiencing sea of thieves
there's never been a better time to play
it we're just really excited
anyway let's get on with the show
as part of expanding air game the
boundaries of the world and the types of
experiences you can have we're bringing
sea of thieves a pirate's life
this features five tall tales that tell
this epic
original story where you get to crew up
with captain jack sparrow
and go on an adventure to save the
pirates life in the sea of thieves
so the idea is that captain jack sparrow
has stolen the greatest pirate treasure
of all time
a golden key to other lands it possesses
true freedom jack has used this treasure
to
cross his precious horizon and he's
found the pirate world of sea of thieves
[Music]
following in his wake is davey jones and
davey jones has also discovered this
pirate world
finding that the pirate's life is
somewhat different here
he has no dominion over those waves and
he doesn't control the pirates life
and their ability to return back from
the land of the dead
and this threatens the pirates life in
the sea of thieves
and as part of this story you get to
work with captain jack
to save the pirates life well i believe
that now is the perfect time to use
these cannons
it's a big part of the story of sea
these are pirates life
is giving players the chance to see
brand new locations for the very first
time
exploring the supernatural realm of the
sea of the damned
and also the underwater world of the
sunken kingdom
so part of these new adventures is
encountering
new creatures in the sea of thieves
world creatures like sirens
they're all around you and engage you in
new ways phantom
pirates that have been abandoned in the
sea of the damned
there's also ocean crawlers
crustacean-like creatures
that work together as a crew we're also
introducing new mechanics
like the trident of dark tides you can
wield it
as part of those tall tales but also use
it to engage with
content that's already there in thieves
like taking it to a skeleton fort or
engaging other ships with this new tool
i don't suppose by chance
there's a second one of those so each
tall tile brings with it
a set of rewards a theme to that tale
there's also
parts of the caribbean themed content
with an air pirate emporium
so we love the idea of players being
able to cosplay as jack sparrow to
cosplay as the crew of the black pearl
to have adventures and have the have the
prison dock with the keys in these
merits as a pet
that you can have in the world and also
being able to deck out your ship
in new cosmetics that feel that they're
inspired by the legend of those iconic
ships
from the parts of the caribbean universe
you can have the
ship set that feels like it's been
inspired by the legends of those ships
coming to the sea of thieves world we're
really looking forward to how players
can role play
using these new ways to express
themselves
[Music]
so i'll never forget that first meeting
that we had with disney i think we
waited till we were around the corner
but then we were literally like arms
over each other's shoulders like kind of
like we're going to do something special
here this is going to be amazing
for this new parts of the caribbean
story we were excited to work with rare
as they are genuine fans of this world
and these characters
and i remember standing kind of the
first moment alone
looking into the mirror and he's ever so
weird almost talking to myself of did
that just happen
with rare we immediately knew we had
found a team that was
up to the challenge of taking what fans
love about pirates the caribbean
from the theme park attraction and the
films and building something new
they looked at our game they recognized
that the tone and the humor
and and the kind of the fantastical
nature of it and everything and i think
they saw
like a kindred spirit i guess we started
by just having fun imagining the
possibilities and pushing each other in
new directions
and i think one of the amazing moments
has been sharing that first initial
creative pitch for where we could
potentially take the story with the team
and seeing that
passion and how inspired that the team
was
to now it's a reality
[Applause]
it was authentic to pirates of caribbean
while staying true to the sea of thieves
everything from the original design
documents to the visual treatments
to what fans are going to experience
when they get to play this we got to
kind of go on all the rides we got to go
on parts of the caribbean twice in a row
which was just so cool for me to see
some of the images from mike's
kind of creative proposal which showed
actually how not just the films were
going to be a focal point of this
collaboration but also the ride
i've been working at games at disney for
over 25 years and i've been coming to
disneyland my entire life
i've probably been on this ride hundreds
maybe thousands of times it's my
favorite ride
this idea that we could put this
creative twist
on these familiar locations that maybe
you've seen on the porch the caribbean
attraction
the idea of representing this almost
director's cut of the attraction
experience
you feel like you're right there in that
tone or in that grotto
even the audio really trying to give you
those really powerful nostalgic
magical moments where you get these
awesome callbacks
[Music]
we looked at pirates of the caribbean as
a real kind of example of the the
freedom of the pirate's life the being
the pirate you want to be of humor
of a really great range of kind of
characters and legendary characters as
well and when we looked at sea of
thieves we wanted to take a lot of that
into our game we knew we had to find a
strong narrative and clear character
motivation to bring jack sparrow into
this world
freedom means everything to jack which
makes the cfd's a perfect fit
but his unpredictable actions make him a
great character to spark the adventure
jack sparrow talks so much about
the freedom of the pirate's life and the
freedom to have your adventures
so the idea that he would want to be in
the sea of thieves world
i want to play as part of saving it was
a really kind of powerful idea the first
time
jack kind of interacts with the ferryman
who is a character from our world
like on the ferry of the damned and
they're kind of bantering back and forth
and jacking the way that he is and his
character and the humor for me that
moment i was like
wow that's captain jack sparrow mate
and i think you may be overreacting just
a smidge
i know the true worth of what i possess
and i intend to keep it quite safe
now i can see you're very busy and very
grumpy
so we'll just be on our way the story
that we've created in cf
is a pirate's life now it's really come
from the heart
and we've really tried to tap into not
only some of the
the feeling of the iconic set pieces
that you see in the movies but really
the deeper meaning of what it means to
be a pirate
and what the enduring kind of appeal of
pirates is
the first moment you you see kind of
characters from our world characters
from their world talking it's like
a magic moment and again it just fits
nothing we can do can understand
how cool this update is going to be rare
has a genuine love of the franchise
and the characters the worlds and the
stories and they understand what makes
them special
this is what has made this so amazing
they bring that
authenticity to every conversation we
have and you're going to see it in the
game when you get to play
[Music]
we had these core characters and assets
that people already knew and loved
and our job was to visualize them into
the sea of thieves and make them
feel like they're part of our world
making sure it's an engaging challenge
and adventure for our existing players
but also something that we hope a lot of
new players
and people new to see if thieves are
going to come in and really enjoy and
want to get all the way through
my favorite bit about that is the
challenge that you then put on yourself
can we bring these really well known
characters into sea of thieves
in a way that still feels natural it
still feels playful and still gives
players those
kind of shared experience moments that
we've always wanted them to feel
[Applause]
it's such a great addition having jack
sparrow because not all players play sea
of thieves
in a big crew with other players some
players feel more comfortable playing
on a solo ship on their own but these
players when playing a pirate's life
they'll have jack sparrow aboard the
cannons whilst they're sailing the ship
which is just such a great experience
we actually got one of the stunt doubles
from one of the parts of the caribbean
movies to come to the studio
full makeup full costume and get to act
out some of these
major moments in their story and just
that encyclopedia of knowledge that
this wonderful actor had really helped
bring jack to life
right down to the mannerisms the facial
expressions
the way he says certain words and how he
how he carries himself
getting jack right was absolutely key to
this story
all of the characters that you see a
part of this story i rather her own team
i even acted at one of the scenes myself
is a lot of fun or it's jack sparrow
the stunt double acting out some of
these scenes to ensure that
it really feels like that character if
we can get him right and if we can
develop the pipeline for him then
hopefully it will go much much easier
for all the other characters he can
fight against
devi jones's ghost ships as well as the
siren statues
he'll tell you when your resources are
on a law and you can find him around the
ship
where you can go and take selfies with
him
we had to make tools that would allow
the animation the content teams the
audio team
to give you that cinematic experience so
there's a lot of different ways that we
can do it but
the main thing is that we just make it
constantly like exciting point here area
of interest there so that players
feel like they're making progress so we
use contrasting color
which goes against the palette of the
rest of the environment
just to highlight key areas of interest
and gently guide
players we'll dress doorways we'll use
assets as leading lines
just to again help guide the player's
eyes to their objective
and there's also kind of cheekier ways
we can do it whereby
a player can drop down into an area that
they then can't get out of to go back on
themselves
as with all of our tall tales players
have a quest book in their inventory
when they start the tall tale
which will always give them guidance on
where they should be going and what they
should be doing
so we have five quest books and
well this is essentially one book where
the castaway
writes down the story and there are also
checkpoints
at various points along the tall tale so
if you do complete part of it and then
for whatever reason you want to come
back to it in a later session there's a
checkpoint
to allow you to pick up your adventure
just where you left off we've been able
to do it in a really authentic way
paying homage to the pirates of the
caribbean ip what it feels like to be
a sea of thieves player in the really
physical playful world that we've built
and also paying homage to the disneyland
ride
and park in general which have inspired
a ton of the design team i know and
probably much wider around rare in terms
of
the level design and the way you move
through an environment
so the tunnels of the damned is this
area that connects the sea of thieves
main world
to the sea of damned so it gives you the
ability
to move from the main world to wherever
you want to go
only that crew is inside that new world
which means that
we have a lot more levers as creators to
make sure that their experience is
unharmed by other players
and all the kind of cinematic beats of
when we want things to happen
all work and play out exactly as we want
them to so it has the possibility
for us to link the sea of thieves world
with whatever we want
my favorite part has been working
together with a team on developing the
sirens
and i absolutely love how the team
brought them together because they are
elegant
they're like these shadows in the dark
that come to hunt you but then when i
get in your face they're like
super creepy one of the things we're
really proud of with the siren statues
is that when you destroy them they do
this
incredible destruction effect it's like
nothing you've seen in sea of thieves
before ever so you get this huge sense
of achievement when you're doing it it
feels like the
the new worlds that we've put in the
sunken kingdom and the sea of the dam
both
they are so cinematic the way we
approach this
we learned a lot from how movies like
parts of the caribbean
do their framing and everything that
sort of grandiose
feeling get in the movies we wanted to
bring that to the game when we started
developing the visual aspect
of the world we immediately started
thinking of
very small objects even things like
flora
and the the sky and the sea what would
this
look like i was quite taking a look at
spanish colonial architecture
with very intricate arches we had the
terracotta tiles
and brickwork and stonework also
plastered
lots of new materials that i got to
explore
we actually found creatively that we
pushed our art style
outside of our own boundaries and it's
really cool because
going forward we found that there's
things in the sea of thieves now that we
wouldn't have envisioned before
this world is mainly a limbo constitute
of memories of
pirates of buildings of their ships
of their adventures it's a memory of
what used to be of what they used to be
and the end result is this magical
beautiful world
with like lots of coral and colors but
equally
creepy dangerous and almost a bit dark
destroy that
so when you dive down from your boats
you actually hear a rendition of who
shall not be returning
which is a song that robin wrote in the
c-band soul update
and it's meant to be that very alluring
sound a siren singing towards you
pulling you into the sunken kingdom
[Music]
with places like pirates grotto and
sailor's grave we was
staying sort of fairly faithful to yoho
pirates lives the tune
when you sort of get out into sailors
grey we wanted to sort of take something
just a bit more sort of laid back and a
bit more ambient almost with it but
still
sort of keep keying off that melody what
we actually
did do is obviously listen to the films
watch the films
and try and bring sea of thieves into
that massive hollywood school ocean
court as we went for a more woodwind
style
which pluckers around every now and then
[Music]
sirens obviously we went for vocals
[Music]
and with the phantoms we actually went
for a little bit more synthy a little
bit more ambient and drones which sits
really nicely underneath everything else
[Music]
this is a nickel harper which we use
quite a lot in sea of thieves you have
these
these keys that you you sort of go
chromatically that you use to play the
notes
playing with a bow you can
[Music]
the character that you made that
initially was just
you know an asset name in an excel sheet
is now
when it is placed into the world and
then you get the voiceover lines on it
and the animation on it
and and the lighting is correct in the
environment
and music comes in and all those things
then
it's very much a case of that the result
is more than the sum of its parts
and seeing everything together from the
concept to then the model the
environments the fear fix the animation
it's been an absolute fantastic
experience
really enjoyed it that moment when
you're in the heavy dark seas
and you're in the middle of a battle you
just look to the left
and jack sparrow is standing next to you
firing at the same targets as you the
music's there
he's there and it's it's like nothing
i've ever played before it really is
something quite special
[Music]
in this first tale of the sea of thieves
a pirate's life you get through straight
into the story
adventuring into the sea of the damned
this supernatural realm
where pirate dreams and nightmares take
on a physical reality
as part of adventuring in this tale
you'll see haunted
grotto caves and the shipwrecked town of
sailor's grave
as you try and find captain jack sparrow
your story begins at the mysterious
castaway
this new character that's come to the
sea of thieves world and has made camp
all the outposts and she's the gateway
to all of these stories
so the sea of the damned is a place
where our players have been before in
the guise of
being aboard the ferry of the dam when
they die before their return to the land
of the living
but in this tale they get to go into the
haunted regions of the sea of the damned
and explore
new locations for themselves
who knows when that evil curse
will strike the greedy beholders
of this bewitched treasure
you'll explore through haunted grotto
caves
hearing all these remnants of the past
and these ghostly whispers
seeing all these dark deeds of pirates
sit closer together and keep your ruddy
hands in board
that be the best way to repel borders
and mark wealthy words mateys dead men
tell no tales
until eventually you emerge into
sailor's grave
this shipwrecked town where damned
sailors a white rescue from the ferryman
and this is a fully realized location
full of these shipwrecked
areas where there's a tavern there's a
gambling den
lots of law reveals lots of secrets to
find so even though players have got the
freedom to
continue that story on their quest to
find jack sparrow
there's lots of things to explore within
that location lots of little moments to
discover
if you follow the trail there's also
reveal of a very special ship there's an
awesome easter egg
to find i won't spoil it but i think it
will really delight our players
[Music]
and on this epic journey through this
new world you'll find a way to reignite
this huge stone lighthouse finding a way
to summon the ferry of the damned and as
part of that journey you'll eventually
find a way
to reach captain jack sparrow i'm
captain jack sparrow
though since you came here to rescue me
you probably knew that already
and you must have heard tell my heroic
journey to acquire this
the greatest pirate treasure of all
so we really wanted to introduce a
character in sailor's grave
the cursed captain this is a character
you carry
in the palm of your hand as he's talking
to you and he gives you a tour of
sailor's grave he can help you find some
of the secrets in the tone
but he also helps you on your quest to
reach captain jack sparrow
we've a long journey ahead and i've yet
to find me sealax
you can play shanties for him you can
leave him behind
you can dance in front of him he'll
comment on all of your actions
so he's essentially this quintessential
pirate captain with all the kind of
one-liners and all the references to
kind of pirate law
he brings that to life in sea of thieves
for the first time this
takes me back cards dice
pitch the pistol i don't recommend
playing that last one with your loved
ones
big surprises early on in their story is
the reveal that not only is jack sparrow
in her world
but david jones has followed him you
think you're there to
release jack sparrow from being held
captured from the ferry of the damned
but it's exactly what davey jones wants
so i won't spoil it too much but davey
jones shows up
right at the start of their story and
you have this awesome cinematic moment
with jack
as you defend the ferry
even from the very first pitch for sea
of thieves a pirate's life that moment
where you first encountered jack sparrow
was just one of those electrifying
moments where
for the first time you're seeing this
beloved iconic character
in the sea of thieves world for the
first time you get to live your own
part of the caribbean adventure in sea
of thieves
[Music]
so now we're going to take a look at the
second tale in the five tales of a
pirate's life
players are diving deep into the sunken
kingdom in search of jack sparrow's
compass
which was still aboard the black pearl
when it was attacked
the compass is the key to what players
will need to save the sea of thieves
so players will be diving deeper than
they've ever been able to dive before
into the sunken kingdom and this is the
home and the stronghold of the sirens
[Music]
you'll see a siren shrine which is a
smaller building but also
the siren citadel which is guarded
and home to the stronghold of the sirens
players will also
venture inside these siren structures
which have been built from coral
and also the ruins of pirate ships
sirens do
drag these ships into the citadel using
these chains
and then break them apart and use them
to
reinforce their structures and also as
methods of
traversal which you'll see throughout
the tail as well for the ocean crawlers
that are in service to them
so they really look and feel nothing
like you've seen in sea of thieves
before
[Music]
players will come across these siren
statues that are harnessing the power of
siren song
and by interacting with these statues
and causing them to sing
in different configurations players can
enact change
using water in the environment so for
example
you may be able to play a rising note of
song
that causes a giant stone face to open
and water to cascade out into the
environment
raising you up and allowing you to swim
to areas that you couldn't get to before
[Music]
[Applause]
we created a sort of breadcrumb trail of
debris that players can follow through
the darkness and the gloom
in order to get that perfect moment
where you see the black pearl
but of course even though you're seeing
the black pearl
it's also a very melancholy moment
because it's chained you know the ship
of
freedom and everything that that
represents is chained at the bottom of
the ocean floor
about to be dragged into this siren
[Music]
citadel
[Music]
with sirens we knew we wanted to go
really deep on making them
feel really fluid really intelligent
really majestic and beautiful creatures
but at the same time terrible and
frightening so
one of the core things that we first set
out to do and prototype
was actually how they move and we have a
system behind the scenes that allows the
sirens to move
in a really beautiful way through the 3d
environment
there are two types of sirens the bass
sirens they will have a scratch attack
where they can come towards you and
attack you really ferociously but at the
same time they can also back off they
will fire a note of song
over to you the sirens and the ocean
crawlers all have this mysterious gem in
the centre of their chest
and the sirens are able to use the power
of that
to create a sphere around them or damage
players
but will heal themselves and any other
sirens that are nearby at the same time
and then a step up you also have siren
leaders so these are
easily identifiable by the fact that
they carry the trident of dark tides
and they will fire this trident at you
and they'll also still come in close and
attack you but they'll do so with the
trident
and again they're able to heal
themselves but their gem is a little bit
more powerful
with the ocean crawlers they're a new
land-based threat
you will find them throughout the tales
but you'll also find them whilst just
adventuring on islands in sea of thieves
and there are three completely brand new
unique
ai enemy types so you have the crab
ocean crawler so this is
the really big ocean crawler that will
come towards you and unleash a
devastating claw pummel attack
you have the electric this ocean crawler
will fire electric-based attacks at you
it will dash around
lightning fast it can also though cast
an
electric shield around the other ocean
crawlers meaning that you need to back
off
because if you get too close to an
electric shielded ocean crawlers
when damage is dealt to them the
lightning will actually chain to you
and anyone else nearby and you'll take
damage from that
and then we have the hermit who uses
spores they're always kind of pouring
out of its mouth and if you get too
close
it will breathe those spores on you and
poison you but it can also burrow into
the ground
and these kind of cracks will appear in
the ground when they burst out they'll
do damage to you
they can also run and charge at you in a
really ferocious attack as well
the trident of dark tides is a brand new
weapon that players will come across as
part of our adventures
in a pirate's life you can also find it
scattered throughout the world of the
sea of thieves
one of the challenges to players when
they're adventuring underwater is
managing their
air and we wanted to deliver a way for
players to
understand that and be able to get their
air back
so that they can adventure for longer in
a way that's really intuitive
so we have these plants underwater that
are really strikingly obvious
and they have bubbles emanating from
them all you need to do as a player is
find one of these plants if you're
running out of air
go near it and it will completely refill
you
players will uncover the fate of the
black pearl and its crew
and players will take part in an epic
battle against a familiar sea of thieves
enemy
in ways never seen before
bringing the world and the characters of
parts of the caribbean
into cfus is just crazy
everybody was totally
pumped for this opportunity when mike
sat down
and started taking people through i was
able to just sit back and watch people's
faces and watching their
smiles light up you know watching
literally tears in some people's eyes
as they kind of were taking through the
story and all sorts of stuff was
genuinely magical
when i first heard about bringing
pirates of the caribbean to sea of
thieves i was here with a spark of
excitement that made me feel like a kid
again
just seeing the characters move but then
with the dialogue as well it started to
feel
like this is disney's actually really
really cool
and this is gonna be this is gonna be
amazing
if i could sum up the project in a
single word i would say
incredible proud magical enchanting
epic i think the project in a word for
me is rare
every time i see it and hear more of the
music or see more of the game or
everything i just think of the studio
and it's it's
incredible it is it is a rare game
through and through i'm
so proud of the team i think there's
been an incredible amount of
hard work and heart and soul that's gone
into this project
incredibly beside myself that it's
happening just this combination of the
these two like sort of pirate passions
that a lot of people have
i'm so proud to have been able to work
on part of it and to help
bring it into being i think the work
we've done is incredible
there's so many cool little references
that we've managed to include
and i hope that those resonate with fans
of both
the ride and of the films there's been a
real
labor of love bringing this project to
life and i can't wait to see players
reactions to it
bringing pirates of the caribbean to the
sea of thieves and seeing those things
treated so well
and seeing them you know such with such
authenticity
and and getting to sail alongside jack
sparrow
is just like a dream come true so yeah
i'm looking forward to your hearing
about it i'm looking forward to you all
playing it but to be honest i can't wait
to get my own hands on it
so i'll see you on the seas
[Music]
thanks so much for joining us for sea of
thieves a pirate's live showcase
it's genuinely been amazing to have the
opportunity to
to show you in so much detail everything
that's coming as part of this but also
just how much it means to us as a team
and as a studio
and for so many members of the rare team
to be a part of this telling this story
and letting you know what's coming
it's been amazing right yeah this has
been an unbelievable journey for us i
mean
it's been such an inspiring project to
work on i can't tell you how excited
i and the team are to bring this to sea
of thieves and
you know just the scope of content and
the way it moves the cfd's world
forwards
i mean just to recap what you've heard
about today you know the five tall tales
that make up that narrative of
see if he's a pirate's life your chance
to embark on this
epic adventure with jack sparrow
encountering new creatures like sirens
ocean crawls and phantoms and exploring
the sea of the damned
and the underwater world of the sunken
kingdom for the very first time
and just how inspired we've been to make
it feel authentic to not only our world
but the world of pirates of the
caribbean now we can't wait for players
to
get their hands on this awesome piece of
content and we can't wait to see your
reaction
and so this is coming free to sea of
thieves on june the 22nd which is not
long now
not long at all and this is undoubtedly
the biggest most impactful update
we've ever added to sea of thieves and i
think that's it from us
so as always we will see you on the seas
cheers
[Music]
you will always remember this is the day
your crew was joined by
captain jack sparrow
to the sea of thieves quick as you like
chop chop
it's time to bridge the worlds and take
our rightful places
as lords of the sea
now we have awoken and we
are hungry perhaps they'll take me
on the grand tour of me fallen kingdom
i was starting to think you'd taken a
tumble not everyone's as steady on their
feet as i
this is the first place i've found where
everyone appreciates
my unique uniqueness
they're coming aboard keep your crusty
claws off me
davey jones wishes you destroyed
and i shall oblige him
what do you start infernal noise
let's catch an infernal noise to you
mate
destroy that statue and they'll be the
double top hey enough of this
hear me my daughter come
[Music]
forth
they've told you it's not true unless
it's flattering in which case
it's all true but they left out the best
bits
[Music]
savvy
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
you